michel sort avait été enlevé le 22 mai
données dernière ainsi que jean paul
kauffmann deux mois auparavant c'étaient
les diplomates marcel carton et marcel
fontaine
depuis ce temps la france a tenté toutes
les voix officielles possible pour
négocier dans libération mais il n'y
avait pas un seul interlocuteur et cette
prise d'otage trouvaient ses
ramifications dans plusieurs capitales
du proche orient avec de multiples
revendications analyse de pierre serra
ces quatre capitales du proche et du
moyen-orient joue le plus souvent les
unes contre les autres
un rôle déterminant sur le sort des
quatre otages français
beyrouth d'abord août où s'exécutent
dans un chaos sanglant
la prise d'otages et quotidienne on les
tient souvent dans la banlieue sud
peuplé de réfugiés souvent miséreux mais
factions rivales ici les restes volaille
ne font pas de quartier
beyrouth c'est à la fois le départ le
théâtre est l'aboutissement de toutes
les luttes
il ne faut pas négliger les groupuscules
qui agissent pour leur compte mais ceux
qui tirent les ficelles sont ailleurs à
téhéran notamment où la révolution
islamique bat son plein
ces mots d'ordre ont force de loi chez
les rays bola du liban les pasdaran les
gardiens de la révolution sont eux aussi
directement lié avec les fous de dieu du
libor le contentieux sur les centrales
nucléaires comme celle ci que devait
construire au dif dans le sud de l'iran
est en voie de règlement
l'iran exige en effet que la france
rembourse le prêt d'un milliard $
consenti par le chat pour ce projet en
1978 mais le règlement de ce dossier que
téhéran ne veut pas lier au sort des
otages
intéressement n'est pas dharan qui
veulent surtout obtenir la libération
des auteurs de l'attentât manqué à paris
contre chapour bakhtiar et qui exigent
comme monnaie d'échangé pour les otages
l'arrêt de l'aide militaire française à
l'irak damas surtout où hafez el assad
le président syrien est au centre de
toutes les manoeuvres diplomatiques et
militaires qui se déroulent dans la
région
il soutient l'iran parce que son hymne
immortel c'est le président irakien
saddam hussein
malgré la présence de son armée ap el
assad est pas parvenu jusqu'à présent à
fermer
nos otages il a déclaré récemment avoir
fait tout ce qu'il a pu mais il faut
croire que son influence ne parvient pas
au liban à contrebalancer l'influencé de
téhéran sur s bola libanais dans les
ravisseurs sont très proches
bagdad enfin en guerre depuis plus de
cinq ans avec l'iran soutenus par les
arabes et par l'occident qui lui livrent
des armes
la guerre n'en finit pas la haine grandi
en même temps que le nombre de victimes
qui se comptent par centaines de
milliers saddam hussein le président
irakien n'arrive pas à prendre le dessus
la bavure de l'expulsion par paris de
deux irakiens a créé il ya quelques
jours un nouveau contentieux avec ceux
qui détiennent à beyrouth
nos otages